[Musica]
sono qui per portare la mia storia che
come vedete è come mutare restando se
stesse
vi racconto la mia storia che è la
storia di una ragazza che unisce una
laurea in filosofia
con un imprenditrice che regalava fiori
durante il lockdown
La storia è un inizio il mio inizio è
questo dopo la maturità scientifica
inizio
a coltivare la mia passione per la
filosofia per la storia del pensiero
filosofico e mi iscrivo
in storie filosofia a Catania
pensavo a 19 anni che studiare filosofia
fosse il modo per
per diventare più saggi e fare sempre le
sue scelte giuste nella vita poi nel
tempo non è stato esattamente così però
al tempo stesso mi dava anche la
possibilità di valorizzarmi seguendo le
mie passioni attraverso la carriera da
insegnante
e fare l'insegnante mi avrebbe dato il
tempo per valorizzarmi anche attraverso
la costruzione di una famiglia quindi
potevo insegnare lavorare a scuola
coltivare la mia passione per la
filosofia
e avere tempo per prendermi cura delle
persone che avevo accanto
una donna realizzata più o meno diciamo
come questa signora tipo nel prendermi
cura di me stessa delle mie passioni e
delle persone che amavo
improvvisamente la vita cambia non era
perfetta la vita che che avevo in quel
momento però era quella che avevo scelto
la vita cambia non perché io scelgo di
cambiarla in maniera
evidente Ma perché le cose intorno a me
cambiano
il posto di ruolo a cui tanto ambivo
tardava ad arrivare nonostante avessi
preso anche l'abilitazione per insegnare
e nel frattempo capisco che la mia
famiglia ha bisogno di me
e così ecco bella di papà mi dice mio
padre
C'è posta per te No in realtà c'era
posto per me
entro in azienda nell'azienda di
famiglia
e quindi abbandono l'idea di insegnare
è il posto pensato per me o quello che
serviva in quel momento in azienda era
il rapporto con le banche
velocemente era gestire conti correnti
che in realtà
era pagare le rate di tutti i mutui
delle società di famiglia ma d'altra
parte io avevo una laurea in filosofia
voi che non ti serve Kant Hegel Platone
per pagare tutti i mutui No in effetti
non mi serviva tanto mi è servito
nell'approccio Mi è servito
nell'approccio perché
perché penso che
potevo imparare a fare una cosa diversa
potevo impararlo perché
avevo accanto mio padre avevo accanto
mio fratello Franco che era già ben
inserito in azienda come tecnico e come
agronomo avevo accanto delle figure
importanti che potevano aiutarmi e in
qualche modo mi avrebbero protetto
nel mio In questo ingresso in azienda
quindi lavoro
pago questi mutui
ma la vita
a un certo momento Cambia ancora
in questo caso cambia drammaticamente
perché papà viene a mancare in azienda
papà aveva fatto l'azienda
e rappresentava per tutti per i
dipendenti per tutti i collaboratori per
noi una figura carismatica è un punto di
riferimento che andava oltre il legame
familiare
era una persona dalla quale si poteva
veramente imparare
mancando mio papà
improvvisamente o realizzo che cambia
anche il peso delle mie responsabilità
in azienda
e mi accorgevo quanto mio fratello
Franco fosse già ben inserito perché era
da tempo che lavorava con papà e quindi
io mi trovavo un po' spaesata quello che
volevo fare era
che gli altri volevo convincere gli
altri o Volevo avere la certezza che gli
altri si fidassero di me e che i
dipendenti si fidassero di me
come penso di fare questa cosa
investendo in me stessa senza
dimenticare la passione per la filosofia
che un po' tra un mutuo e l'altro era
stata messa da parte diciamo la verità
Allora mi scrivo ad un master in
marketing e comunicazione digitale Al
Sole 24 Ore
dove tutti mi domandavano sempre ma che
fatturato fai Ma la tua azienda ma io
sto in Sicilia un'azienda produco fiori
Sì ma il fatturato e ho capito Sto
fatturato cioè c'è anche altro forse nel
frattempo Un amico mi regala un libro di
Adriano Olivetti e da lì Inizio a
leggere tantissimo il suoli vecchi
alla cui figura Tra l'altro era stato
molto spesso avvicinato mio padre leggo
tanto e Olivetti è davvero tanta roba
qui ho sintetizzato una frase che
sicuramente molti di voi conosceranno
è proprio di Olivetti la fabbrica non
può guardare solo all’indice dei
profitti deve distribuire ricchezza
cultura servizi e Democrazia Io penso la
fabbrica per l'uomo non l'uomo per la
fabbrica bene Io leggo Leggo continua a
leggere e un'idea cambia le mie visione
delle cose
realizzo che le aziende non sono solo il
fatturato come volevano farmi credere i
miei colleghi del del master a Milano
sono in realtà espressioni di valori
e quindi io inizio a pensare che la mia
azienda dovesse essere capace di
esprimere la sostenibilità quando parlo
di sostenibilità parlo di sostenibilità
in senso ampio
pensavo che
quello che determina l'azienda e il
successo di un'azienda non fosse solo il
fatturato anzi il fatturato era una
delle chiavi possibili del successo di
un'impresa
Perché quando si entra in un'azienda
si entra non nella struttura in quello
che produce nelle tecniche che possono
essere utilizzate nelle coltivazioni di
un fiore
si entra in un'idea
si entra nell'idea che l'imprenditore
con i suoi collaboratori vuole portare
al di fuori dell'azienda
le aziende sono
dunque non sono strutture ma sono
delle comunità sono delle piccole
comunità
sono delle comunità fatte di persone di
donne di Uomini che lavorano che hanno
il tempo e la voglia e la volontà di
esprimere se stessi non solo attraverso
il lavoro
ma lo fanno anche attraverso le
relazioni che riescono a instaurare
dentro l'azienda in cui lavorano
relazioni che possono essere fatte di
inclusione di accoglienza di
disponibilità di apertura verso tutti i
loro colleghi stranieri perché
nelle nostre aziende Abbiamo tantissimi
collaboratori stranieri
e come comunità la prima sostenibilità
che sulla quale volevo investire era la
sostenibilità ambientale
l'azienda partecipa alla realizzazione
di una comunità energetica perché quando
pensiamo a comunità oggi e pensiamo
all'ambiente
la comunità energetica è perfettamente
coerente no essere comunità energetica
significa per un'azienda
essere Sì condividere condividere
condividere i benefici Certamente
economici perché c'è un risparmio nella
comunità energetica nelle realizzazioni
di una comunità energetica Ma c'è anche
un beneficio che è di tipo sociale
perché condividere i benefici e
dell'energia e condividere il risparmio
con altre aziende
e fare una
sostenibilità sociale così come
sostenibilità sociale è pensare ad una
collaborazione
con con l'asp di riferimento per delle
Campagne di screening e di prevenzione
contro il tumore per tutti i nostri
collaboratori le donne per il tumore al
seno gli uomini per tutti per i melanomi
per
tutti per tutte le
Le possibili
per tutti i possibili tumori
ed essere fare sostenibilità sociale
significa anche iniziare questa
collaborazione non solo della nostra
azienda ma coinvolgere anche tutte le
altre aziende
per esempio quelle del tua stessa
associazione datoriale Nel nostro caso
confagricoltura e ti accorgi di come
facendo rete è unendosi si diventa più
forti e veramente si fa qualcosa che ha
a che fare con la sostenibilità sociale
sostenibilità sociale
è anche pensare
di portare l'arte dentro l'azienda
nelle aziende agricole È raro trovare
momenti di musica o di condivisione di
vari artisti dentro
dentro uno spazio riservato di solito ai
collaboratori e a tutti i dipendenti Noi
abbiamo provato a farlo Quindi
coinvolgere un jazzista di fama
internazionale magari pure siciliano e
dirgli vieni in azienda
a suonare un po' di jazz perché io sono
certa che ai miei dipendenti piacerà
ed è stato così infatti
dire al vescovo della propria diocesi
vieni in azienda e parla con i miei
dipendenti ma non con quelli cattolici
con alcuni di quelli che si mettono
nell'ora di
nell'ora del pranzo
vanno via dalla loro dalla loro mensa
estendono un tappeto a terra per pregare
è bello il confronto in realtà di queste
di queste diverse
figure no
questo è fare sostenibilità sociale
accogliere
uno shooting fotografico per una nota
marca di scarpe e borse dentro Le Serre
in mezzo ai fiori e far vedere i
dipendenti che esistono forme diverse di
bellezza
c'è il quadro di Giotto c'è c'è
Botticelli c'è l'arte c'è il jazz di
Francesco Cafiso
c'è anche la bellezza dei del Lavoro
sano c'è la bellezza dei dipendenti
c'è una bellezza che in realtà è comune
a tutti Bisogna solo saperle leggere
quando
quando si dice che la bellezza salverà
il mondo
che è una bellissima verità
Forse
bisogna andare ancora più su è il senso
del prendersi cura che salverà il mondo
perché se capiamo che veramente
c'è un se ci concentriamo sul prendersi
cura
e pensiamo che prendersi cura non è solo
prendersi cura dell'ambiente ma è
prendersi cura degli altri e prendersi
cura della persona che hai accanto dei
tuoi dipendenti dei tuoi colleghi
la bellezza si mostra da sola non c'è
neanche bisogno di andare a convincere
gli altri no
e
mi piaceva mettere questa immagine
perché questa immagine
sintetizza un po' l'idea che che noi
adesso abbiamo delle nostre aziende
dentro questa immagine c'è la bellezza e
la cura di cui vi parlavo prima c'è
un'azienda che esce fuori dai propri
cancelli in un momento difficile che era
quello della pandemia del lockdown
e sceglie di regalare tutti i mazzi di
fiori
che qualche dipendente è rimasto in
azienda
raccoglieva dopo essersene preso cura
per tre mesi
e di regalarli di regalarli
insegno anzitutto di
Dono No proprio come un dono che potesse
colorare le case di chi è di tutti noi
c'è anche
la celebrazione
e il rispetto per il lavoro di questi di
quei dipendenti sempre perché
forse più degli altri
Chi fa che nel settore dell'Agricoltura
ha più il senso del prendersi cura
lavorando con piante
e quindi regalammo questi fiori messi
fuori dalle generi alimentari dai
tabacchi proprio per dare questo segno
di speranza
e in questo senso mi piace
ricordare che il crisantemo che è il
fiore di punta che è la nostra azienda
produce
è un fiore considerato sacro in Giappone
Perché in effetti la pianta del
crisantemo è una pianta che in natura
fiorisce solo in autunno quando in
realtà la natura muore
E allora i giapponesi hanno dato a
questo da questa fioritura
un significato di ritorno alla vita di
speranza
mentre da noi è più legato al culto dei
defunti Chissà perché invece è un segno
di speranza e di ritorno alla vita
ed è quello che volevamo comunicare con
con questa
con questi bancali con tanti mazzi di
fiori che ognuno prendeva e portava a
casa
mi aveva molto commosso
in quel momento
quando tutto era chiuso
e anche il cimiteri erano chiusi che è
un vecchietto
anche un po' claudicante aspettava
aspettava che il tabacchino aprisse per
prendere questi fiori e portare un
Mazzolino di fiori alla foto del figlio
nel salotto di casa sua perché non
poteva più andare al cimitero in quel
momento
e io qui ci ho visto tanto amore per la
vita
Quindi quello che ho voluto dimostrarvi
in questo con questo breve racconto È
che molto spesso la vita ci costringe a
mutare io
immaginavo di fare l'insegnante di
filosofia un po' come la signora Retrò
molto molto ventesimo secolo diciamo
mi sono trovata a fare altro e usare in
qualche modo il mio approccio è la mia
formazione umanistica
e quindi
sono andata incontro al cambiamento
pur mantenendo la mia autenticità che
non è perfetta
però sono autentica Grazie
[Applauso]